>> Well, I'm here at the Davos summit and
have followed meetings and
followed conversation.
Of course, one of the big topics of the discussion
here is how do we
create a safer banking system?
And what has created a lot of interest is
what the President of the
United States, Obama, has said about both
limiting sort of the riskiest
activities that retail bank undertake like
large-scale proprietary
trading.
And also looking at the idea going forward
of a banking levy to better
protect taxpayers against the instances of
banks getting into trouble.
Now both these ideas are ideas that myself
and the British Conservative
Party are very interested in, we'd like to
see this done
internationally.
This is an international banking industry
and talking to people here at
Davos, both officials and politicians, you
get the sense that there is
quite a lot of support for this.
It's a big challenge.
How do we have successful financial services
for as many thousands of
people, make sure Britain remains a great
center of global financial
services while at the same time protecting
the British State and making
sure that the banking customers is serving
its customers instead of
serving the businesses and it's spent on its
credit.
So lots of interesting discussions.
I feel that what the British Conservative
Party has set out is the
right direction.
It's certainly with the mainstream of thinking
here.
And I look forward to -- I've got one more
day left, seeing what the
people have to say about this.